rentré à 15h30 roland martin on va
s'occuper de son foyer préparer le repas
du soir
évidemment il aurait préféré que sa
femme reste au foyer mais racheter une
maison même à crédit ça coûte cher
[Musique]
depuis 1946 l'égalité professionnelle
est reconnue en droit alors les femmes
étant à l'époque principalement
considérés comme des mères la loi vise à
les protéger au travail pourtant la
constitution proclame que la loi
garantit à la femme dans tous les
domaines des droits égaux à ceux de
l'homme
en 1972 une loi pose le principe de
l'égalité de rémunération pour un même
travail ou un travail de valeur égale
mais concrètement vous était à l'école
jusqu'à quel âge 14 ans et monique 24
ans j'ai donc ni l'un ni l'autre vous
n'avez de formation professionnelle de
nude et vous retrouvez là au bout d'un
certain temps avec une différence de
salaire
oui j'ai puis je ne comprends pas vu que
les femmes
la loi du 4 juillet 1975 interdit de
rédiger une offre d'emploi réservé à un
sexe de refuser une embauche de
licenciés en fonction du sexe ou de la
situation de famille sauf motif légitime
mais la féminisation de certains métiers
a encore un peu de mal à passer trop de
métier n'ont pas encore de féminin l'esa
vient en 1976 la directive européenne du
9 février introduit la notion d'égalité
de traitement qui vise à passer d'une
égalité formelle à une égalité réelle
la directive en juin les états à prendre
des mesures afin de supprimer toutes les
dispositions discriminatoires envers les
femmes est contraire au principe
d'égalité de traitement
retour en france pour une réflexion sur
cette vieille maxime bien bafouée à
travail égal salaire égal
une loi pourtant été voté il ya cinq ans
pour que les salaires des femmes soit au
même niveau que ceux des hommes pour un
travail de même valeur au cours des
années 70-80 la population française
prend progressivement conscience de la
discrimination faite aux femmes en
matière d'égalité professionnelle et
salariale
quels sont ceux où seuls qui gagnent
moins de 650 francs par mois
trois jeunes filles
aucun garçon pourtant de nombreuses
mesures ont permis aux femmes d'avoir un
accès à l'éducation et aux formations
monsieur en stage de menuiserie vous
formez aussi bien des hommes que des
femmes
est ce que vous faites une différence
dans l'enseignement un enseignement non
c'est exactement le même travail que les
petits fonds
les femmes comme les hommes mais dès
qu'il s'agit de se faire embaucher et
ensuite au niveau de l'emploi il ya une
différence l'emploi on a toujours eu un
problème pour placer les jeunes filles
où les jeunes femmes qui sortaient de
chez nous les artisans qui emploie les
ouvriers tic toujours un peu pour
employer des siècles de conditionnement
ça ne se renverse pas en deux coups de
cuillère à pot
pour vous il n'ya pas de métier au
masculin non comme je pense qu'un apport
féminin c'est donc au niveau de l'état
comme au niveau de la société que tout
ça doit changer de nouveaux codes et de
nouvelles habitudes à prendre
heureusement les bonnes volontés existe
et depuis votre faim de travail vous
vous êtes mis à faire écrit si ça me
vient c'est dans ce contexte qu'ils
vivent et rudi députée européenne nommée
ministre des droits des femmes impose
une loi pour l'égalité professionnelle
qui prend en compte l'aspect sociétal du
problème c'est à dire que nous vivons
dans une société où seuls ceux reconnus
comme travailleurs les gens qui ont un
salaire ou une entreprise ou qui ont
pignon sur rue c'est à dire que toutes
les situations des femmes qui pour des
raisons diverses qu après tout qui les
regardent ou qui regardent à la famille
puisque la décision est prise en famille
se sont arrêtés d'avoir un travail
salarié peut rester chez elle et se
consacrer à t-elle telle ou telle tâche
les enfants peut être aidé le mari et
c'est l'extraordinaire injustice c'est
qu'elles deviennent invisibles
elle ne compte plus pour ça elle va même
aller jusqu'à diffuser des spots de
publicité à la télévision
non arrêté dans la vie professionnelle
les femmes en trop d'obstacles à
franchir formation restreint débouchés
sont nombreux salaires inégaux ce n'est
pas normal ça doit changer
aujourd'hui encore les hommes touchent
en moyenne 23% de plus que les femmes
chef de l'état avait abordé le problème
dans sa dernière conférence de presse il
avait souligné qu'il s'agissait bien
plus d'un problème de moeurs que de loi
un problème de moeurs qui dure déjà
depuis bien longtemps et qui évolue
lentement très lentement
j'espère bien qu'on ne va pas faire du
ministère des droits de la femme une
institution permanente
non mais il n'y a aucune raison qu'on en
est encore besoin au 21ème siècle
combien faudra-t-il encore d'année pour
expliquer aux femmes leurs droits et aux
hommes leur devoir une étude de l'insee
de mars 2011 montre qu'une personne sur
4 continue à penser qu'en période de
crise économique les hommes devraient
être prioritaires pour trouver un emploi
les femmes conserve aujourd'hui encore
une image de personnes - disponible que
les hommes puisqu'elles doivent
concilier leur vie professionnelle et
leur vie familiale
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne peut
pas pondre qu'on ne peut pas couver
le plus incroyable sans doute fait cette
étonnante animal c'est sa reproduction
les rôles sont inversés la femelle
transmet les oeufs au mal et c'est le
père qui va porter la couvée jusqu'à la
délivrance
[Musique]